well they're known as birds of prey
trained wild animals used to keep
residential and commercial areas clear
of rodents and other unwanted pests a
rare form of art being practiced right
here in las vegas christian casada shows
us how it works and who's behind it
we can use the predatory behavior of a
bird of prey to trigger the fear
response in small birds or small mammals
or whatever because they're born
instinctively to have that fear factor
a unique task dave canelli says he has
mastered over the past 40 years a hobby
that has turned into a full-time job
come on buddy
so this is ranger he's a working bird
ranger is a hawk and was bred in las
vegas but his origins are from peru
which canelli says makes the bird
smaller a crucial factor making it more
agile and faster the bigger the bird he
says the more room they need to work i
can make this bird go anywhere i want by
shining a laser beam at it i've trained
him to do this so i can put him in a
tree that might be have birds in there
and actually get him
to go investigate that area cannelli
says one of about five thousand
falconers around the country he says
it's a lost form of art now practiced as
a sport he's taking it to the next level
and helping southern nevada eliminate
unwanted visitors you might get some
birds that want to come into your french
fries or chips or your chips and walk
knock over your drinks you know they did
you know they like to steal the little
sugar packets and the sweetener packets
they get to be kind of a kind of a pain
and you know the birds themselves aren't
as big of a problem it's what they leave
behind dave and his wife operate
airborne wildlife control services here
in las vegas requests for their services
coming in on a regular basis from both
on and off the strip and even the
airport during that migration time
nothing's more appealing than a big flat
wide open airport flat ground to rest
so these birds will land out there by
the thousands and when planes are coming
or going they get sucked into turbines
so they don't take down every plane so
they can take down a plane you remember
scully and the hudson raptors and
falcons are trained he says to disperse
all the birds each one with a tracking
device around their leg now we've got
the greatest technology we have gps we
can look at our iphones or a tablet or a
computer on google earth and see
a real time dot
exactly where the bird is and drive
simply straight to that spot and pick
the bird up their unique talent even
catching the attention of one of las
vegas newest sports team the vegas
nighthawks and quickly becoming the
team's mascot
as the heat rises both on and off the
field kenelli's focus is on his birds of
prey and their skills christian casa is
live local now
that's pretty cool canelli says the
birds require years of training and
constant attention he says they are wild
animals and their instincts can kick in
unlike dogs or cats who are certainly
loyal pets